A number of golf courses have recently been built in Korea.
According to the government, more than 100 golf courses will be constructed over the next few years.
Some say that the more golf courses the country has,...
...the better it is for the economy.
Their arguments are that new golf courses will create jobs,...
...and will attract tourists from other countries.
They also point out that building large golf courses could increase foreign investment.
But others say that building golf courses damages the environment.
Also, as far as the benefit of increased employment opportunities is concerned,...
...they say that a new golf course mostly creates part-time jobs,...
...which would not provide long - term job security for the workers.
Many people support the above opinion by saying that building luxurious golf courses...
...widens the already - existing gap between the rich and the poor.
They argue that the country does not need any more golf courses...
...that are constructed at the expense of the natural environment.